happy Thursday reject nation of Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey I'm getting over
a cold right now that was very sick all
day yesterday I have to go to movie
fights later today I probably should
have cancelled now stupid on me got it
yeah or something got a new champion
ever
yeah find your way back up to the car
back up what good's a champ if you can't
perform when you're not feeling well
am i right I'm sure Elton John sometimes
performed on stage when he wasn't
feeling well John's never not felt well
John I'm trying to transition of course
subscribe to the react nation like that
notification bell Rocket Man the
official trailer before we hop into this
I would like to say thank you to
everyone who is following us over on our
patreon page over there we do weekly Q&A
s
TV show reaction stream alongs for show
such as my hero academia I just finished
all of attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood John's done most
of Riverdale he's just moved on to the
haunting of Hill House right now I
started up one punch man gotham
supernatural we also have reaction
highlights included as of this month for
certain shows and that includes
supernatural one punch man my hero
academia thanks john fisher you gave him
a back he also does music video coverage
music videos yay oh and Johnna links in
some way we're taking too long to get to
this trailer right now I know I know
that's how you do a trailer tease it is
the best one it's a little bit funny
[Music]
[Music]
Reginald white that's my person you
wanna be nice I like that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I wish I know more it was great yeah
it looks like a really rousing fun movie
yeah it's gonna have its biopic tropes
and everything there's little nuggets of
things that I I really like that make it
stand out I mean in that moment where is
reginal as the person who mainly wrote
songs with right Oh Bernie Taupin oh
that's Bernie to his Reginald is my
journal Dwight is his real name he took
I don't know who is he talking to in the
mobile where he's yelling at him
this is growing pretty reg Dwight yeah
yeah but even in that moment where he's
yelling at him that usually just seemed
like such a biopic moment yeah yeah
normally in anybody just gone on stage
you're like man it's got really good
greedy and very egotistical didn't it
you know so having this little human
moments like that I know Elton John is
very directly involved with this movie
all his company produced it I mean III
don't know how a lot of times that gives
people faith when you hear things like
that but after seeing if he Amy in
Rhapsody and even harder with even green
but a lot of times with these biopic
there's someone for the real life
involved with the biopic a lot of times
it doesn't really lend itself to being
authentic yeah you're like how many of
the the warts are we going to cover up
yeah you know glamorized is this gonna
be and i you know i really wonder cuz i
you know Elton John seems like he could
take at least a little bit of ribbing
but I
I always now especially since Bohemian
Rhapsody I'm kind of wary of how you
know how much historical correction is
going to happen through this well it
seems like they're gonna really commit
to it this time around and what I also
what I also really I just love we
touched on the teaser trailer there's
is a lot of the fantasy element sort of
stepping into the imagination of Elton
John you know like you call it a Rocket
Man I think is very appropriate like
that I don't know rocket man to be his
most famous song I've heard like goodbye
yellow brick road or even this is your
song or song yeah I've heard those are
you usually higher up on the list of the
Elton John tracks but I think Rocket Man
is a good encompassing one for him
because of you know it's about a
spaceman imagine yeah it's a good
metaphor for the man yeah it's very
appropriate for especially with what
we're seeing with the visuals
accompanying this movie and Taron
Egerton secretin or Edgerton I don't
know yeah gotta look up an interview and
see how is know he looks like he's gonna
do a really terrific job every by Pixar
usually a sure way to get yourself that
Oscar nomination yeah and they make it a
big deal all the fact that he's singing
all the songs himself he can actually
sing and I always prefer that always
yeah even if I never expect the actors
vocals to match the actual singers
no these are gonna be better it's gonna
be better right Wow I prefer this over
because it does sound different but
there it lends itself to a level of
something that feels much more authentic
you know and I mean that's partial
that's a big part of what kind of pulls
me out of that live aid performance in
Bohemian Rhapsody is I'm like man so I
keep thinking it's like just the best
lip-sync performance and it's not so
watching him here like he has to
communicate that emotion through his
voice you know not just the body
language this time around
man the costume design here in the
productions like the vibrant colors here
this looks like I just a beautiful
[ __ ] film oh he's beautiful
well that's I mean intrinsic to Elton
John too because I mean even before he
started getting like
super crazy with the costumes it seems
like he always had a sense for
showmanship in the sense for you know
they they they say that thing at the end
of the trailer Valley he was always such
a shy boy and I got to imagine like you
know that was part of you know going
against that for the state yeah I'm
gonna dress as big as I can or at least
in these you know matching elaborate
costumes and stuff like that I mean I
believe there's there's some biopics
where you hear you're there like you
know there's struggles to be unique and
they're they're criticisms of being who
they are and it feels kind of just
glossed over and I feel like it's very
essential to this experience we're gonna
go on with Elton John the character in
this movie only I hope they do
truly unique figure and his style
especially was just so out there that I
get why people would like had like the
moments hear those criticisms I imagine
really did happen and where people were
up and in front of his face like just
really judging him for it yeah and I
think that it's you know is it essential
quality to this film you know cuz
there's that scene in Moe he I keep
comparing this book you know it's like
of course you're going to Bohemian
Rhapsody just came out I think that the
you know we're starting to see what this
new wave of biopics feels like
especially with the people the subjects
so involved now you know yeah I mean
who's next one was Billy Joel village
sure why is the famous gay singer let's
do Bruce Dickinson Iron Maiden let's
switch over see who has some heavy metal
like I just you know whose name I mean
Georgia like wait we're friends George
Michael George Michael yeah there we go
well right I mean I mean theoretically
it wasn't was an Elton John by doesn't
matter I mean you know make a choice man
we going that was a joke by the way I
didn't really mean that no okay well
before we wrap this up I would like to
give a page from the day shout out to a
lady of our Channel
of a patreon page [ __ ] Rosa para yeah
Rosa this is this this patron shout it
is your song right here Rosa I hope you
enjoy it you hope you enjoy this film
you make me want to fly to the space
like a rocket man like a rocket man you
know you just really get me going and
you make me move my emotions so much I
started moving like a like a tiny dancer
just for you Oh hold me closer Rosa para
yeah and sometimes I go through tough
times but I'm still standing cuz of you
singing your song yeah Crocodile Rock it
is sometimes I just want to move so fast
like baby in the chest yeah how much you
move my heart but we're making a
sacrifice right now to not move so that
we can be here to make this everyone oh
can you feel the love tonight Rosa yeah
someone saved my life tonight and it was
you oh look there's a skylight and
pigeon mm Saturday nights alright but
you know what I love the most is
Thursday mornings because that's when we
give Rosa Paresh out alright five
patreon seem yeah movie 5 Slater